wir hatten es schon war haftbefehl web
analyse goodbye dich versteht man sehr
gut deutlich besser als kassen fehlen
aber es gibt einen titel jetzt auf dem
album mutter da gibt's noch einen dicken
part der unter ständig ist und nicht
weil du nur schützt sondern du singst
deine muttersprache fast genau das
sprechen die perser dialekt noch oder
ist es einfach dem gastraum ist alle
person sprechen und modern heißt es so
es halt über meine mal wieder da ist
dass auch das persische wort für mutter
oder nicht ist es eine verballhornung
von mutter es ist das ist ja das aber
das gibt scheint wirklich das wort so
modern und das benutzen glaube ich dir
schreibe es anders aber zum beispiel
leute aus afghanistan nutzen das auch
und ich glaube ich gibt es ein paar
andere länder um ihn herum wie das auch
den dass auch häufigste begriff und ich
hab da halt mal wirklich auch versucht
was anderes zu machen und ich habe mir
gedacht wenn ich jetzt ein song für
meine mom mache und da muss ja immer
persönlich sein und ich habe halt
natürlich geguckt dass ich im refrain
die sprache benutzt mit der sie mich
aufgezogen hat das heißt also meine
mutter spricht normaler jetzt
mittlerweile gutes deutsch aber ich
wollte trotzdem noch mal so einen
persönlichen touch geben der ganzen
geschichte plus für mich war es wichtig
dass die leute den zahn fühlen und das
war ein experiment das hat auch daneben
gehen können aber ich wollte dass die
leute das fühlen nicht nur verstehen
das heißt natürlich gibt es viele iraner
die das dann direkt übersetzt haben
worüber ich mich auch freuen natürlich
aber viele schreiben halt einfach dass
sie kein wort verstehen sie es aber
fühlen und es ist cool finden es klingt
für sie cool
okay das war auch ein bisschen so dass
dinge womit wir gespielt haben also bzw
mit dem element habe ich gespielt hat
ganz gut geklappt warum was ist da jetzt
was wie heißt dieser also ich sag ja
madonna fasste man hasst das heißt das
für die mutter du bist mein atem
du sollst vor fröhlichkeit vor
glückseligkeit immer tanzen das schade
die heimische belasten
wobei strategie dieses wort an sich gibt
es gar nicht so im vorsehe
das ist aber authentisch weil ich sie
wie es ist ich hab einfach geschrieben
und bin ins studio gefahren habs
aufgenommen ein perser anrufen einen
guten freund von mir oder einen cousin
oder sonst was auch immer da vielleicht
der sprache mächtig ist als ich und
freuen können ist das so richtig was ich
sage aber falls einfach authentischer
okay ich bin gefahr gelaufen dass das
falsch ist so dieses wort gibt es
vielleicht im umgangssprache könnte man
das vielleicht noch so durch gefühl
toleranz aber es ist abgeleitet von
einem worten das heißt schon okay so
ich habe wie gesagt ich vielleicht
besser deutsch als persisch das heißt
spricht noch die wahrheit ich besser
durch als persisch farsi und die
gemische belastet zu sein in der methode
giotto weitere sag ich da und das heißt
soviel wie keine frau dieser welt kann
ein platz einnehmen
roland krüger am balkon
das heißt so viel wie ich oder ich
spreche jetzt gerade damit selbst gott
mir glaubt sodann offenbar das ist
eigentlich so dieses was dahinter steckt
das große geheimnis der hut aber es
haben so viele mittlerweile das einfach
übersetzt und bei youtube unter die
kommentare geknallt das ist deutlich
viele mitbekommen haben
aber das ist schon der sinn das ist ein
geheimnis ist dass davon inhalt
miteinander kommunizieren voll in den
strophen wird deutlich worum es geht und
das war nicht halt auch einfach mal cool
um die sprache sage ich mal seiner die
heimat seiner eltern zu repräsentieren
mit etwas positives hat das gefühl dass
die leute das immer mit etwas negativem
versuchen zu assoziieren so die wollen
sich dadurch im ii profilieren oder
härter darstellt als es ist ich verstehe
gar nicht warum ich finds echt peinlich
für die menschen weil ich repräsentiere
in dem moment meine herkunft meiner
eltern und dann sollte es mit etwas
positivem verbunden ist die sprache und
wenn ich dann das aber benutzen zum
beispiel sagen zu würde
ich bin iraner ich [ __ ] dich und noch
ein iranisches sword dann einbauen würde
ich finde einfach dass das das
deklassiert die anderen leute aus meinem
land
wir haben das nicht verdient dass es so
dargestellt wird ich wollte es mit etwas
mut mit etwas positivem anziehen
okay was hat meine mutter gesagt ich
wusste wie meine mal darauf reagiert
beziehungsweise ich hab mir gedacht und
aus diesem grund habe ich ihr das nicht
selber vorgespielt ich wusste ja wann
das video rauskommt hat mein vater
gesagt dann und dann guckst du darunter
an und zeigt mal das geheimnis für sich
behalten hat sie dann gezeigt und dann
ziemlich das telefon
sie hat sich natürlich gefreut drehen
und er hat all das war einer der
hauptgründe natürlich auch eine hommage
an alle maß dieser welt mine welche
frauen sind für uns unser leben lang da
so das sind halt die maas und die
verdienen respekt und ich wollte mal was
anderes machen als das was so viele
andere rapper machen nicht dass das
nicht cool finde ich wollte einfach auch
mal stellten dann für mich selber setzt
nach
wie ist das für dich wenn menschen so
auf deiner musik reagieren ist das
geschenk für dich oder also das beste
geschenk das man haben kann ich glaube
natürlich ich bin musiker ich lebe davon
so ich bin rapper ich lebe davon aber am
ende des tages ist unbezahlbar wenn
leute nach dem konzert zuge kommen und
sagen der und der sohn hat mir sehr viel
gegeben oder der untersten supergeil wir
hören jedes mal wenn wir wohin gehen
oder bemühen vom fußballspiel sondern
motivieren und damit das gibt ja etwas
das kann kein geld der welt zurück geben
sondern es natürlich geld das der
schritt gut dann würde ich wünsche dir
dass du oft noch diesen steht erlebt ich
mir auch